lawyers for social media companies say
Russia continued to spread false
information online even after the 2016
election the Senate Judiciary
Subcommittee yesterday questioned
representatives of Facebook Twitter and
Google with lawmakers wanting to know
how Russia back propaganda spread
unnoticed to millions of Americans Nancy
Cordes is inside the hearing room where
the Senate this morning we'll be hearing
from Senate Intelligence Committee and
they'll be asking questions as well
Nancy good morning good morning that's
right the executives from those three
social media Giants will face more tough
questions today about how exactly they
are tackling this problem of Russian ads
and fake news that plagued the 2016
election yesterday those executives from
Twitter Facebook and Google told
Senators that a internet an internet
troll farm based in st. Petersburg
Russia set up 120 Facebook pages where
it posted more than 80,000 pieces of
content over two and a half years and
here's what happened next all that
material was delivered directly to the
news feeds of approximately 29 million
American users who then shared it with
millions more not knowing that all of
this information was actually coming
from Russia Minnesota Democrat Al
Franken wanted to know why such
sophisticated tech companies didn't spot
the problem sooner you can't put
together rubles with a political ad and
going hmm those two data points spell
out something bad in hindsight it's one
we know okay okay yeah Facebook's
attorney said that those Russian ads and
posts did not stop after the election in
fact they just changed their focus and
were aimed at sowing discord in the
country and raising doubts about
president Trump's legitimacy they say
that this is a sign that these trolls
were more intent on creating chaos in
the United States than they were on
focusing on one particular candidate
thanks Nancy